Well,
let them prick me and I don't bleed
that I am shocked
because the news we have received
this morning the truth is that Gallina's skin,
because who would have guessed
that the acting President of the Government
and the presidency of the incumbent government
were going to reach an agreement in order to be able to form
in their case 1 government if they had
the majority for the investiture?
Therefore,
I believe it is 1 news item.
Stop the rotary
because no one could expect Pedro to lose
and Yolanda 10 could reach this agreement
and especially Yolanda Díaz,
so firm in their convictions,
in its principles,
so radical,
of course,
in the approaches it makes,
but which nevertheless does not seem to
who,
by maintaining the vice-presidency,
has been able to.
But I insist,
stop the presses because it is 1 news item.
that no one expected.
Now this agreement
is as valid as Pedro's word,
i.e.
none,
because without the endorsement of the independentistas
and of the Filhuaetarras,
this is wet paper,
the same as the word
worth absolutely nothing
and therefore the Spaniards
we should not be surprised
that they could reach an agreement
the acting President of the Government
and Vice President
in operation,
which would certainly surprise us.
or we should be surprised
to all of us who consider ourselves Democrats,
is that the future of Spain
to be agreed with those who staged a coup d'état,
with those who certainly do not abjure
of the Tarra Fair
because they have not yet condemned her
strictly,
with those
who will not take the oath of Princess Leonor
next Tuesday
and with which,
however,
both Pedro and Yolanda Díaz
cling desperately to their attempt
to remain part of the government.
In other words,
this agreement is worthless
without the endorsement of those who want to break through Spain